The best local agent harness in 2026 is
not the one with the most GitHub stars.
It is the one that developers running
agents all day keep coming back to. And
that answer has changed. A year ago, the
question barely existed. Today, it is
the only question that matters because
the models have largely converged and
the wrapper around the model now decides
your entire experience. One word will
keep coming back in this video.
Reliable. Hold on to it.
Past the feature screenshots, past the
star counts, reliability is what
actually separates these harnesses on
real work. Keep four things in your head
as we go. The harness itself, the model
you point at it, where that model lives,
and what you are actually asking the
agent to do. Every pick in this video is
really about matching those four. Get
one wrong and the other three don't
matter. Start with the headline. The
model race is over. It ended in a tie.
Claude Opus 4.8 hits 88.6% on SWE-bench,
verified, the highest published number
in this category right now. GPT-5.5 in
the Codex harness leads Terminal bench
2.1 at 83.4%.
Gemini 3.5 Flash is right there at 76.2.
The differences are real, but they are
shrinking every month. What is not
converging is the harness. The same
model in two different harnesses gives
you two very different outcomes. A
researcher put this question directly
into a public post this year. Why does
Claude Code feel so much more effective
than running the same Claude model
inside a different tool? The answer is
the harness. That is the whole point of
this video. So, which harness do you
actually start with? If you have never
run a local agent before or you have
tried one and given up because the setup
was a nightmare, the answer is the same.
There is one name the community keeps
pointing newcomers toward and it is not
even close. Open Code is the default
open source pick of 2026, no qualifier.
If you want a single safe starting
point, this is it. It has crossed
172,000
GitHub stars, the most starred open
source coding agent on GitHub with 1.68
million weekly NPM installs as of June
2026. It is MIT-licensed, model-agnostic
across 75 plus providers, and it runs
local models through Ollama and any
OpenAI compatible endpoint. No code
leaves your machine unless you tell it
to. The harness is genuinely deep. You
get custom primary agents and sub-agents
defined in JSON or markdown, each with
its own model and its own permissions.
It supports MCP, agents, MD context
files, and LSP integration across 20
plus languages, which means the harness
loads language-aware context
automatically rather than making you
manage it.
The architecture is client-server. Run
open code serve and you get a headless
open API server for async and remote
use. Install the whole thing with one
curl command. The community sentiment
around it is unusually clean.
People post, unprompted, that its
terminal interface is better than the
bigger, better-funded names.
One caveat worth knowing up front:
Anthropic prohibits Claude Pro and Max
subscriptions in open code. So, if you
want Claude underneath, you need an API
key, not a subscription. That is not a
deal-breaker. It just means you pay per
token rather than per month.
Open code is the pick when you want
maximum provider flexibility, a deep
harness, and the ability to run entirely
on local hardware.
But, flexibility is not always what you
need. Sometimes you need control.
Surgical, precise, reviewable control
over every single line the agent
touches. And for that, the community has
a completely different answer, one that
has been quietly winning for 3 years and
nobody talks about enough.
Aider is the original. It has been doing
this since 2023, and it is still the
best at one specific thing: disciplined,
Git-native editing. That is not a
consolation prize. For a huge portion of
real coding work, it is exactly what you
want. What makes Aider different is how
it treats Git. Every AI edit becomes one
atomic commit with a written by the
model commit message. Your Git log reads
like a change log. If the agent wanders
off or makes a bad call, you revert one
commit and you are back. No hunting
through a tangled history. No bundled
whip a bunch of stuff. The repo map it
builds from your Git repository gives it
a structural understanding of your code
base, not just the files you hand it.
>> [snorts]
>> It is also the most model flexible
terminal harness available today. The
Aider leaderboard tracks 70 plus models.
You can run GPT-5 for the hardest
refactors, switch mid-session to a
cheaper model with a single
command, or point everything at a local
deep seek or Qwen model via Ollama for
fully offline work.
Mid-session model swaps are one command
away. No other harness makes that as
seamless. The honest catch, Aider does
not natively support MCP as of mid-2026.
There is an open RFC and third-party
workarounds exist, but if MCP is a hard
requirement for your workflow, this is a
real gap. It also does not pretend to be
an autonomous overnight runner. Aider is
a pair programmer. You are sitting
there, reviewing each change as it
lands. For surgical, commit-by-commit
editing with full model freedom and Git
as your safety net, nothing beats it.
Now, both of those harnesses, OpenCode
and Aider, are tools you run. You
configure them, you point them at a
model, you stay in control.
But some people do not want a tool they
run. They want a foundation they build
on. They want to look inside the loop,
rewire it, strip out what they do not
need, and add what no one else has
thought of yet. For those people, there
is a third name, and it comes from
someone you probably already trust.
Pie is the breakout newcomer and the
most intellectually interesting harness
in this list. It comes from Armin
Ronacher, the person who created Flask
and Jinja, and it shows. Pie is built
around one idea. A A should be small
enough to understand and hackable enough
to make your own. Its core runs on a
sub-1000 token system prompt using what
it calls lazy skills, modular
instruction blocks that only load into
context when the task actually needs
them.
A standard coding task does not load the
deployment skill. A browser task does
not load the get skill. The result is a
harness that stays lean and sharp even
on large contexts. Because it never
blows itself with instructions it is not
using that session.
This architecture is the reason Pi keeps
coming up as a foundation for custom
agents. People are not just running Pi,
they are building on it. Open Claw, one
of the most discussed personal agent
projects of 2026, was directly inspired
by Pi's design philosophy. A powerful
agent living on a minimal surface.
If your goal is to understand and
control what your agent is actually
doing at every step, Pi is built for
that from the ground up. The trade-off
is that Pi is less polished out of the
box than Open Code. You get more control
and less hand-holding.
For someone who wants to wire their own
tools and own their own loop, that is a
feature.
For someone who wants a running agent in
20 minutes, start with Open Code. But
here's where it gets interesting. A
harness is only half the setup. Every
one of these tools is only as good as
the model you put underneath it and
getting that pairing wrong is the most
common mistake people make.
For most local setups, the model
community keeps circling back to Qwen
327B dense, reliable, fits on a single
24 GB card, and runs on a used 3090 most
people can actually afford. Four-bit
quantized builds from Unsloth are on
Hugging Face and ready to drop in. For
bigger jobs that need more memory, Qwen
3.5A 3B is the mixture of experts
alternative, where idle experts sit in
system RAM and only the active slice
needs to live on the GPU. Speed will
come up. Local is not instant. On a 3090
you are looking at 37 tokens a second.
The pros stop fighting that and run
parallel agents instead through Volm as
the serving layer so the card is busy
the whole time rather than idling
between tokens. Volm is not a harness
for one deep refactor. It is what you
reach for when the answer to slowness is
more agents, not a faster one. The
privacy case for local is now the
obvious one. For client work under an
NDA, your prompts and your code never
leave the machine. No repo uploaded, no
tool call sitting in a log on someone
else's server, no policy email next
month. A used GPU paid once against a
monthly subscription that compounds
forever. Within a couple of years, the
local box is simply cheaper and it never
changes its terms. One name worth a
separate mention, Claude Code from
Anthropic is the deepest proprietary
harness in the field by most measures.
It has 30 life cycle hook events,
dynamic workflows for orchestrating
parallel sub-agents, and leads SWE-Bench
verified at 88.6% with Opus 4.8
underneath. The community call on it is
unusually one-sided, the best coding
agent in the market and it's not close
is how the top upvoted thread describes
it. It is not free and it is the
heaviest token spender in the category,
roughly three to four times heavier than
Codex on the same task. For programmable
terminal depth, nothing else matches it
right now, but it is not local and it is
not open, which is the whole reason this
video exists. So, line the whole field
up and it gets clean. Want the open
source default with maximum provider
support and a deep harness?
Open Code.
Want disciplined, commit by commit
editing with total model freedom and Git
as your safety net?
Aider. Want a hackable base to build
your own agent on top of? Py. Want
autonomous, unattended runs in CI or
self-hosted infrastructure?
Open Hands. Want the agent loop inside
your editor?
Kline.
Want a general agent that goes beyond
code?
Goose.
Most heavy users end up running two.
They route surgical edits to Aider,
autonomous longer tasks to Open Hands or
Open Code, and swap models freely
underneath based on what the task needs.
The honest caveat, this list has a shelf
life measured in weeks. Rue Code was
archived in May 2026. Gemini CLI stopped
serving individual users in June. The
projects that looked stable 6 months ago
are not all still here. Before you
standardize a team on any of these,
check two things: the actual license and
the date of the last commit. Stars show
popularity. Recent commits show whether
the project will still be running in 6
months. But, the direction is clear. The
model race ended in a near tie at the
top. What is still moving is the
harness. Pick the wrapper that fits how
you actually work, point it at the model
your hardware can run, and the local
stack stops being a compromise and
starts being the obvious choice. If this
saved you a weekend of testing,
subscribe, and I will see you in next
one.